we're going back to other auditions in
your career what was the worst one and
why what was the toughest one oh we have
a lot of actors that watch our stuff so
there's never I'm one of those guys that
I don't think auditioning is acting like
it's an art form in itself that I don't
it's never copacetic it's never easy
it's never nice it's usually very cold
and I mean it's nine times out of ten
it's it's everything but an ideal
situation to go in and try to get a job
so to me they're all equally hard yeah
the suck level is equal to all of them I
mean there's no I mean like you always
saying you know you expect to recreate
this sort of whole thing and it's this
it you know what I mean so it's like you
you have to strip it down to the bare
essentials of just connecting with
another human being and just let enough
unis sort of shine through that to see
what you know there you know give them a
taste of what they would be getting and
hopefully they see those moments so you
know you've put those moments out there
enough that they're buying into it let's
say you sit in a chair and I mean wait
what
you know how far can you really go with
it you know it's like it once you have a
job it's like you spent months preparing
for it but with an audition and a lot of
times you're expected to come up with
all that stuff in a day yeah do you get
it last night you're gonna go in
tomorrow morning ray the script is come
up with what you would normally come up
with in a month you know so yeah as far
as like I mean the worst I don't
this one was like was definitely the
most intense that it sticks out in my
mind is like but like you were saying
I'm gonna get the gift of what the
casting director did for me and that was
that he he did he stripped away all of
that and it became about just like human
connection and like the bare bones of it
so when we shot the scene there's
there's so much going on you know and
there were there were special effects
and there were people running and
screaming and all of this but like the
reason that it's horrifying is because
you're watching somebody lose somebody
you know so that's that's basically what
he was getting to and and you don't I
mean I don't know that every every
producer and director has the
imagination in an audition scenario or
or even casting director but I don't I
don't think they usually do so that's
why when he told me like just sit down I
was confused and I was but it I mean it
worked out obviously but uh
you